former President Jimmy Carter calls
president Trump's choice for his new
national security advisor his worst
mistake since taking office the 39th
president brought up John Bolton's
appointment when we sat down for an
interview yesterday your faith in
President Trump well as I say I've been
concerned that some of the things he's
decided I think his last choice for my
security adviser was very ill-advised I
think John Bolton has been the worst
mistake he's made he's advocated going
to war preemptively against North Korea
against Iraq against Iran even and so I
think that that is particularly your the
advise because they're not security
advisors I know from experience is the
most listened to advice that a president
yes but I still think that our country
can overcome in the president's new
national security adviser has advocated
a preemptive strike in North Korea what
would that do that would be a total
disaster we could precipitate a nuclear
war which would be horribly destructive
and we're gonna hear more from former
President Jimmy Carter in our next hour
we talked to him about President Trump's
decision to meet with North Korea's
leader and his new book faith a journey
for all being released today it's
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS News I also talked to him about
stormy Daniels so we'll have part of
that as well coming up all right looking
forward to that